Transcription: Elise LECAMP
Relecteur: Hélène VERNET
Bonsoir !
La place des hommes dans la mixité,
c'est ce que je vous propose
d'explorer ensemble, ce soir.
À l'origine, il y a un choc.
Nous sommes le 14 octobre 2010.
Je suis au « Women's Forum » à Deauville.
Sur scène, Anne Lauvergeon prend la parole
devant les environ
mille femmes qui sont là.
Elle est un peu énervée ; elle nous dit :
« Écoutez mes petites chéries, ça suffit !
Ça fait presque dix ans
qu'on travaille sur la mixité
et la progression des carrières
au féminin, or, il ne se passe rien.
D'après vous, pourquoi ?
Regardez autour de vous !
Qui manque-t-il d'après
vous dans la salle ?
Où sont les hommes ?
Les hommes représentent
entre 83 et 90 % des postes de Comex
dans le monde occidental.
Ils représentent donc
entre 83 et 90 % des décideurs.
Or, ils ne sont pas là.
Ils ne sont pas là
pour comprendre avec nous,
entendre, et agir.
Alors maintenant,
invitons-les à la table. »
Quelques mots sur moi :
je suis la quatrième
d'une fratrie, après trois garçons.
J'ai donc passé ma jeunesse
à essayer de les comprendre.
Nous avons tous les quatre
bénéficié d'une éducation
relativement peu stéréotypée.
Mes frères étaient
de toutes les tâches ménagères,
moi, de toutes les parties
de foot, et inversement.
Et, lorsqu'il s'est agi de faire
des choix d'orientation,
j'ai été, là encore, peu touchée
par des standards féminins.
C'est ainsi qu'après un professeur,
un prêtre et un agriculteur,
j'ai été la première de la famille
à entrer dans le monde des affaires.
Vous allez me dire qu'avec
un schéma familial aussi classique,
il manquait le militaire.
C'est moi qui m'y suis collée
d'une certaine manière,
car mon premier poste a été
pour les forces armées canadiennes.
Et ce qui a servi de décor
à ma première expérience professionnelle
a été un gros bain de virilité.
Un autre choc, qui m'a
engagée à m'intéresser
à la question des hommes
au sein de la mixité,
c'était justement dans ces années
canadiennes, dans les années 1990.
J'ai remarqué que - et c'était récurrent -
les relations hommes-femmes
étaient un peu faussées,
c'est-à-dire que les hommes
étaient un peu timorés,
osaient peu faire de l'humour,
et tout ça parce qu'ils étaient assez...
plombés par un féminisme
qui était, à l'origine, très, très dur
en Amérique du Nord.
Ça s'est, depuis, beaucoup
plus équilibré, Dieu merci !
De retour en France,
je découvre les réseaux féminins,
les réseaux professionnels féminins.
J'y entre avec grande joie.
J'y trouve des femmes formidables,
des rôles modèles,
des femmes qui sont restées
des exemples pour moi, beaucoup d'amies.
J'y trouve un cocon au sein duquel
je peux parler de ma vie professionnelle,
et je découvre même que
j'avais des freins que j'ignorais.
J'apprends, en particulier,
à négocier mon salaire,
à le négocier comme un homme,
c'est-à-dire de manière
décomplexée, factuelle.
Et, la réflexion que je me suis faite
à l'issue de cela, c'est :
oui, nous avons des freins,
nous les femmes -
la prise de parole, la mise en avant,
la négociation salariale -
mais ça n'est pas insurmontable.
À partir du moment où on décide
d'être sensible à nos freins,
et que l'on met les moyens
pour les dépasser, on peut y arriver.
C'est un message
que j'ai continué à garder,
et que je passe aux jeunes
professionnelles aujourd'hui.
Forte de ce choc initial de 2010,
avec Anne Lauvergeon, je me dis -
puisqu'entretemps, j'étais devenue
co-présidente de ce réseau -
je me dis : « Nous allons
tenter une expérience,
une expérience nouvelle :
nous allons engager les hommes.
Nous allons embarquer les hommes,
en tout cas, essayer. »
C'est ainsi que nous avons créé
une série d'événements
où les hommes étaient invités.
Nous avions dans la salle
50 % d'hommes, 50 % de femmes.
Et nous avons commencé à discuter
ensemble de nos rapports respectifs
à l'argent, à l'autorité,
au pouvoir, aux stéréotypes.
Et là ! Ô surprise !
Contre toute attente, j'allais dire,
les hommes qui étaient là
étaient extrêmement enthousiastes.
C'était très « fun ».
Il y avait beaucoup de bonne volonté
et ils étaient prêts à embarquer.
Il est vrai que dans la salle, avec nous,
certains avaient été amenés
par des membres du réseau.
Donc, certains étaient peut-être là
de force, mais, quoi qu'il en soit -
comme peut-être certains
dans la salle, ce soir -
il y avait beaucoup
d'enthousiasme et de bonne volonté,
et je me suis dit : « Mais,
mon Dieu, quel puits de soutien !
Quels leviers de changement ! »
Alors, j'ai décidé de ne pas en rester là,
et d'essayer d'agir et de les engager.
Pour cela, j'ai commencé à rencontrer,
avec mes camarades,
beaucoup d'experts qui nous ont aidés
à comprendre où étaient les hommes,
afin de mieux les engager.
Première découverte !
Un autre choc, un grand choc :
les piliers de la masculinité.
Que sont les piliers de la masculinité ?
Ce sont ces comportements
masculins stéréotypés
qui vont faire dire d'un homme :
« Ah oui, c'est un homme ! »
Alors, quels sont-ils, ces piliers ?
Premièrement : être un leader.
Deuxièmement : ne montrer
aucune fêlure dans l'armure.
Troisièmement : être un
meneur d'hommes, un vrai mec -
vous avez différents exemples
stéréotypes de vrais mecs -
et surtout, n'avoir rien de féminin.
Là, je me suis dit : « Ce collègue
qui n'arrête pas de me couper la parole,
qui veut toujours
parler plus fort que moi,
s'accapare mes idées en réunion,
en fait, ça n'a rien de personnel !
Ce sont ces piliers
de la masculinité qui parlent. »
Première découverte !
Deuxième découverte, encore plus forte :
le syndrome d'Atlas,
du nom de ce dieu grec
qui a été condamné par Zeus
à porter la Terre sur ses épaules
jusqu'à la fin des temps.
Alors, le syndrome d'Atlas,
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire,
quand on parle des hommes ?
Cela veut dire que les hommes,
de manière inconsciente,
sont élevés, depuis
qu'ils sont tout petits,
avec cette idée qu'ils vont devoir porter
la charge financière de leur foyer.
Qu'est-ce que ça signifie ?
C'est une injonction de réussite.
Cela veut dire, pas de choix :
il ne faut pas montrer ses émotions
et réussir, aller très haut, très vite.
Vous allez me dire, nous, les femmes,
avons beaucoup d'autres freins -
ils sont multiples, et on les connaît -
beaucoup d'obstacles dans nos
carrières, mais, on n'a pas celui-là.
Comme le dit Pierre Bourdieu :
« La virilité, c'est un privilège,
mais c'est aussi une charge. »
[Peur. Ignorance. Apathie]
Troisième découverte
qui est une conséquence,
un corollaire de
ces deux premiers concepts
des piliers de la virilité
et du syndrome d'Atlas,
ce sont les freins que les hommes ont
quand ils souhaitent
s'engager dans la mixité.
Ces freins ont été étudiés par un institut
qui s'appelle l'Institut Catalyst,
un institut américain.
Ils sont au nombre de trois :
premièrement : la peur,
la peur de s'engager parce qu'ils
auraient peur de dire des bêtises.
Ils auraient peur du regard de leur pairs,
peur de perdre leur statut,
parce que s'engager pour la mixité,
ce n'est pas super sexy.
Donc, la peur.
Deuxièmement : l'ignorance.
J'ai été surprise et je
continue d'être surprise
par le niveau de méconnaissance
de beaucoup d'hommes
sur la question de la mixité :
les chiffres, l'effet du plafond de verre,
les disparités salariales.
Tout ça, ce sont des choses que beaucoup
d'entre nous, les femmes, connaissons,
mais que les hommes connaissent très peu.
Donc, s'il n'y a pas de problèmes,
pourquoi s'engager ?
Enfin, l'apathie.
L'apathie, c'est cette sorte
de paresse, si je puis dire.
« Moi, je suis un homme.
Je vois assez bien ce que
je vais y perdre, dans la mixité.
Je vois assez mal
ce que je vais y gagner.
Pourquoi je m'engagerais
pour quelque chose
qui va me faire perdre quelque chose ? »
La conséquence de tout cela -
des piliers de masculinité
et du syndrome d'Atlas -
les conséquences sont dramatiques.
Il y a plusieurs types d'hommes,
en tout cas, il y en a deux.
Il y a, vous le connaissez,
celui qui va se se conformer
aux piliers de la masculinité,
va se conformer à cette injonction
de réussite venant du syndrome d'Atlas,
et il va s'investir dans la sphère
professionnelle à 200 %,
au détriment des autres sphères
familiales, spirituelles, etc.
C'est toujours plus haut,
toujours plus vite.
Rien n'existe, il faut
réussir à avoir un statut,
avec les conséquences
qui vont avec.
Il y a un deuxième type d'hommes,
que vous connaissez aussi.
Ce sont des hommes qui sont plus
en défiance par rapport à tout cela,
qui ne s'identifient pas,
qui ont un autre système de valeur,
mais qui vont quand même essayer
de rentrer dans cette boîte
qu'on leur impose.
D'ailleurs, c'est intéressant de voir
que ces deux types d'hommes
ne se comprennent pas forcément.
Quand vous en avez un en présence
de l'autre, le dialogue est difficile.
Mais, quel que soit le type d'homme,
les conséquences sont les mêmes.
Et elles sont dramatiques.
C'est-à-dire qu'il y a chez les hommes
beaucoup plus de « burn-out »,
de violence envers soi-même
et envers les autres,
beaucoup plus d'alcoolisme.
Il y a trois fois plus de suicides
chez les hommes que chez les femmes,
et une durée de vie plus courte
chez les hommes que chez les femmes.
Alors, je ne veux pas
plomber votre soirée !
Je vais essayer de terminer
sur une note optimiste,
parce qu'on est quand même là
pour essayer de voir
comment on va les engager,
ces hommes-là !
Maintenant qu'on les
connaît un peu mieux,
et qu'on a réussi à capter
davantage leur psychologie,
voici quelques pistes.
Comment les engager ?
Tout d'abord, il y a le langage,
les formes de communication.
Le langage est important,
c'est très subtil.
Je pense à un titre
de presse que j'avais lu.
C'est probablement le titre
qui m'avait le plus choquée.
J'en ai lu, depuis, beaucoup.
« Quand le Comex se féminise,
c'est bon pour l'entreprise. »
Cet article faisait état d'une étude
qui montrait que la mixité dans les Comex
donnait de meilleurs résultats, soit !
Mais, moi, je suis un homme,
en train de boire mon café le matin,
en train de lire mon journal,
un quotidien économique.
Je lis ça et je me dis : « Ça veut dire
que si on pousse la logique jusqu'au bout,
il faut de plus en plus
de femmes, voire que des femmes.
C'est un discours essentialiste
qui m'écarte complètement.
Je n'ai pas envie de m'engager
là-dedans. C'est un suicide. »
Donc, utilisons des mots
qui soient plus appropriés
et moins anxiogènes pour les hommes.
Autre idée, c'est de les inviter.
Alors, il y a les réseaux
internes d'entreprise,
les réseaux externes également.
J'en vois beaucoup, aujourd'hui,
qui sont en train de devenir mixtes.
Ça ne veut pas dire qu'il
ne peut pas y avoir des zones
où les femmes vont se parler
car elles ont des choses à se dire,
et les hommes vont aussi parler entre eux.
Ce qui est important et ça revient
à l'idée d'Anne Lauvergeon,
il faut les inviter à la table.
Il faut qu'ils apprivoisent le
vocabulaire, apprivoisent les concepts,
pour pouvoir ensuite s'engager
et engager leurs équipes.
Une autre chose à laquelle
les hommes sont très sensibles,
c'est l'engagement des patrons.
Ils ont besoin de symboles forts.
Il faut des mecs, des vrais, des patrons
de grandes boîtes qui s'engagent,
qui parlent en interne et en externe.
C'est pour ça qu'il y a, aujourd'hui,
beaucoup d'actions menées
pour que ces hommes-là -
en tout cas ceux qui sont convaincus -
s'expriment davantage.
Alors pour presque finir,
une autre chose :
la forme de communication.
C'est difficile pour nous, les femmes,
qui travaillons
sur les thèmes de la mixité
et celles qui sont victimes
de discriminations,
de voir la question avec légèreté.
Mais, je pense que la légèreté
est importante et l'humour aussi
quand on parle de mixité.
Enfin, ce qui engage les hommes aussi,
c'est de voir que les femmes s'expriment,
qu'elles prennent la parole,
prennent le pouvoir sans complexe.
Et voilà !
C'est ce que TEDxChampsElysées
permet ce soir.
Alors, merci TEDx.
Merci Béatrice Duboisset,
et merci à toutes !
(Applaudissements)